this mag daddy is the mack daddy of
burgers I don't like the word daddy but
[Music]
I'm Kelsey this is my friend Annie today
we are trying another Instagram famous
food we're at trade in Irvine California
and we're going to be trying pic ten
delicacies famous mac daddy burger it
has macaroni and cheeses the but beans
very overboard but great hi my name is
Kevin Bobby one of the cofounders of Big
Bend delicacy what are we trying today
today we're doing the Mac Daddy burger
it's ones made out of mac and cheese
super super crazy is we boil the pasta
make our own cheese sauce mix it in with
one of the patties we let it cool down
and then from now we're able to thank go
crust them and then we deep-fry it cook
the patty and then throw on a couple
slices of candied bacon can't go wrong
with more cheese so we throw a little
bit of more cheese on top you know
you'll be really surprised at the
flavors what was their reaction to the
Instagram thing it was crazy at first
our team was a little bit overwhelmed
people drive from all over to come here
and like hey I got a try it's like a
novelty item that people come and travel
just to try so excited to try today all
right it was doing did
oh my gosh my heart is pounding because
your arteries are clogged I mean maybe
but also men are really happy about it I
can smell the barbecue I was very male
about the right usage I don't know
[Music]
yogurt it's so nice and salty it's so
juicy the cheese is really soft and
creamy but the crunch is incredible
that's something you don't get in a
burger normally and it's really
satisfying a lot of flavor going on the
breading reminds me a little bit of
tempura there's cheese in every crevice
of this cheese in the meat as she's in
the mac and cheese also I'm not just
intolerant just a reminder sorry any I'm
gonna die are you at least having a
happy death yeah yeah this would be a
really satisfying last meal before bed
so oh yeah it kind of hits all the notes
the mac and cheese on this side is so
appealing this beautiful this is a work
of art there's a good amount of
sweetness from the barbecue it's sweeter
than you would expect a burger to be but
in a really nice balanced way because
all the saltiness a lot of textures so
many different textures I'm surprised
it's holding together I feel like it
should be crumbling by the law of
physics this is worth at least an hour
and a half drive this does not be bacon
for more I'm sorry a little cheesy oh my
god
who's the burger daddy don't say that